when the trailer for dark pictures house
of ashes debuted on a live stream
it was one of the conferences
playstation maybe i don't remember
i promised that i would do a full
playthrough of it and here we are i'm
going to play through this entire game
on my youtube channel which is kind of a
cool callback to my first ever
playthrough which was until dawn and i
think this is the fourth game in the
dark pictures anthology i played mana
madan on the channel
there's a little hope maybe there's one
i'm missing i'm not sure but um
we're gonna jump right into it i'm a big
old scaredy cat but it's scary month so
let's
do it and yeah i thought this looked
really neat
um
challenging me a good a nice medium
a nice medium
seems fine
use a lot
i like the setting of this
i'm interested in the story
but i'm also sure i'm going to get
real spooked
for they have sown the wind and they
shall reap the whirlwind
every choice has a consequence aka
people will die
some decisions save lives
others
lead to
death
oh no
choose wisely
i will do my damn best
are you alive
no
oh
oh oh it's like one of those clown games
no i think they're fine they're just
playing a fun
clown game
it's a carnival you know the way you try
to get the ball in the mouth it's i
think they're fine
i don't want to die silence your words
are meaningless here
your blood will pay the debt our king
demands your sacrifice will lift his
girls from our land
forgive me my lord the king demands
urgent presence well you get that baby
oil down here dog
how do you get that shiny for now
take this one back to himself i'll deal
with him later
you're in luck gutierrez
i remember there being monsters in this
though
it's not
this temple is cursed i'd rather die in
this cursed house
than perish to the plague and famine out
there
we have our orders captain
he's wearing like something on his beard
that was cool as hell
like a beard skirt
damn
the moon god sends you to destroy
um subtitles for everybody sorry about
that
subtitles
all
that should be it
yeah
okay
sorry about that
i see everything
look around you
is this whole not payment enough for my
mistakes
it's a nice hole dude i'm not going to
deny that bask in its glory
the gutens are coming general
the moon god sends an army to destroy us
i shall muster our forces immediately
good
and what news from below
there are hundreds of prisoners making
their sacrifice will take time we're
sacrificing all of them time is no
longer in our hands
no matter
the blood of this army will nourish the
sands the sacrifice will be fulfilled
starting with this one
oh my
i wonder if tell me general
does she remind you of anyone
my king do you not see a hint of your
own daughter in her
that's what age would she have okay
dude 18.
18.
chill out a bit what a tragedy this
plague has been
kill her who'll be asking those kind of
questions i mean
i feel like i have to to be compliant i
feel like i have to
why your command
i was gonna say i wonder if we'll have a
section where we play in the past and a
section where we'll play in the future
because that could be cool
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm just obeying orders he
seems mean
oh baby oil is back
[Music]
it just seemed like that i
that's you know i needed to obey him so
i didn't die
i you know i'm a soldier
i i want to be clear this is not what i
want the outcome to be
okay well you did that one all on your
own
i didn't have any part in that decision
my gosh
wow that what a throw
oh boy
youtube is not gonna like this it's only
been six minutes
demonetized
what do you mean there was a beheading
in the first six minutes
oh boy okay
i feel like i'm on the side of the
prisoners but it also kind of seems like
the soldiers
oh
boy
oh gosh um the soldiers are like under a
tyrant right it's not like they're
inherently evil either
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a dope hole dude but you look
lonely as hell
the nice holes are wasted on the lonely
that's what the dude's heads were like
the clowns
[Music]
you're gonna go blind you need to wear
sunglasses to do that
oh it's an eclipse
i should mention
i'm playing um an early build uh very
thank big thanks to um
it's bandai namco australia if you give
me a code
um
the pop-in may not be there when the
game actually comes out
that is often a thing fixed in a day one
patch
hmm
that doesn't sound like people
gods give me strength
everybody's dead
even him huh
oh maybe this is where the car starts
with the eclipse
what are those
oh geez school
yeah i don't feel like you guys need to
fight i feel like this is unnecessary
there are bigger problems outside
[Applause]
we thought
he built this temple to call for
forgiveness
but the gods don't listen
and now he too is silent
hmm
he had it coming
viking
free of his madness now as are we all
we can't stay here forever
that is gonna snap quickly what are they
is it gonna be undead soldiers
hmm
help me with this
i need to turn that off
i can only do holds i can't do taps
break my thumbs but i believe they said
they have uh
good accessibility options for that i
have tendinitis i can't rapidly mash
buttons follow me make some video games
very difficult to play
yes
for the builders when they're done
come
i would think that was a person if it
didn't make that guttural sound
and i guess that confirms they're not
blind
a and time with the heartbeat okay
this is a cool mechanic
oh boy
oh did it get faster i think it did
just rat
how many men died for our king
their sacrifice bought them nothing
press and hold rt to pick up objects
auto examine that's the same as all
their games i think they usually get
like a little flashback or something if
you look at them the right way
in this case a bug
not my favorite actually not mine bugs
okay
find the secret exit
what's this
premonition
hmm
i mean we don't know what'll lead to
that isn't that sort of the thing with
these games is you can usually find out
like
one choice will lead to one thing like
that
this doesn't look like a very category
entrance but
help me with this
may as well take a look
did actually go to the catacombs last
time i was in
paris
makes you feel um
you first
it's just like a kind of introspection i
don't think anything else has ever made
me feel before
just like looking at skulls piled up and
they're real skulls and you just kind of
like
huh
what is this that adorns you
nothing to concern an acadian
how do we get out of here alive
um i think that you probably should help
each other
the enemy of my enemy
is a friend
we help each other
there is always hope
that camera angle was real spooky
how many ways into this
we're not alone down here
oh boy
over here
i don't love that
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine just
shut it off doors
open by themselves all the time oh
well
as you were gentlemen
hey that look
all right
no shame
it's been difficult to get manicures
during the pandemic you can't
hate on anybody
for not being able to
make sure they're as presentable as
possible when businesses have been close
you know
we've all been there
i don't know the plan is you guys
there's no escape or only hope we're
gonna stop we're gonna fight it no
if we both run then we both die
ready okay
for the achievement
oh no i hope
i didn't just kill them
boy oh both oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Applause]
oh no
i don't have a lot of confidence right
now
you go to a doctor about
your back situation it's probably not
sorry you guys
sorry
about that
that is my bad though it may have
happened anyway
oh boy
seems fine i'm sure he's fine
[Music]
i forgot about these weird like music
intros they have for these games
[Music]
yeah
this guy
i feel like they were both supposed to
die there
that's what it feels like
there's probably nothing i could do
about it
because yeah if i remember correctly
the modern part is a bunch of
excavators or soldiers potentially even
go to
this
area
modern day
[Music]
so
yeah that was probably just like a
little
prequel bit a little story intro for ya
supermassive games not to be confused
with supergiant games who made hades
supermassive duo until dawn
and the dark pictures anthology
they did um
a psvr
uh
i think it was an until dawn roller
coaster
pretty sure or it was just a like a
spooky roller coaster in general i'm
pretty sure they made one
if i remember correctly
[Music]
so cool dude
on the edge
your survival depends on the choices yes
they will be as a compass
guiding you through the unknown
as is in life my friend salvation
will be lost in the darkness
forever
let me speak plainly
you're about to make some difficult
decisions
decisions that will affect the lives
how those decisions play out will become
clear
over time
i expect you're wondering who i am and
where you are
i am his face looks very good
my purpose is to keep a record of
everything you do
every decision
or mistake
you make
this is i get like micro expressions
it's wild
stories stories about friends and
enemies
enemies frail life
and death
understand
that i am not here to help you
although
i have been known to bend the rules
from time to time
this is a very cool character intro
to descend into the unknown alone is
extremely brave
or extremely foolish
[Music]
perhaps there is more to you than meets
the eye
let me give you a few words please i'd
love to hear them throughout the story
you will encounter certain pictures
pictures which allude to possible yes
i suggest you pay attention to their
meaning
it could foreshadow i was never good at
reading those
but alas
sans have time to run out for us we'll
meet again soon to see how you feel
or fail
all right
let's go
i feel like it's probably gonna be safe
for a bit that's what happened with the
lost one of these that they played it's
like the start like kind of felt
safe you're just getting another
character's
contextual info
zac efron
jason goldcheck
confident intolerant
eric king rational and insecure
i wouldn't have thought those two often
get paid together welcome to camp slayer
you're early
apologetic
apologies we're arriving early
lieutenant things are moving fast i hear
you colonel i'm glad to have you on
board
techs are ready for your presentation as
soon as we get word from the ceo we're
good to go
you should read this
he looks familiar
didn't you hear
there's a new king in the castle looks
that way
you are
um
this is my assistant clarice stoke
doctor clarice stokes my home gold check
first lieutenant cole check
wow
the briefing room
i don't remember i think you're supposed
to play them in accordance with the
traits like i'm supposed to remember
what they are in play like
he's rational and insecure i should play
that that way
oh
oh my oh oh
okay
what's up maureen
can't you keep up
rachel king is commanding and abrasive
got it she's an [ __ ]
nick k is defensive and romantic oh
buddy
i love him already this could be our
last time together rachel
after what happened at the checkpoint uh
i thought i was done
these last few weeks you've you've
lifted me up
i don't know where i'd be without you
baby
i've already forgotten everybody's names
she's rachel rachel king
colonel king has arrived on base man
he's on route to the briefing room i'll
be there in five
[ __ ] it's him he's early your husband
you mean
oh
don't you think it's about time you came
clean
put your clothes back on straighten up
all right rachel drama already drama is
a foot
you and eric have been apart for a year
whatever you had it it's got to be over
come on um
say nothing
say no more
i get it
i feel sorry for him i hope he lives
great wings you did a great job with
that eyeliner go
please teach me
garbage i don't know what i'm doing what
is this what have i done
you'll have to excuse the noise and
disorder we're just getting the base
shut up
blows my mind
only a few weeks ago saddam was living
it up in here
drowning down in candy bars
nice pool
nice image
if only you could see the state of this
place now
makes me smile
we got the cia we got the army the
marines dia the air this is a really
pretty environment
everyone wants a piece of history
god bless you
i see you old man keep busting out those
reps
hey you come join me
maybe i'll teach you there too
later we have company
yeah
this here would like to watch me get my
sweat on nice you want to spot me little
lady let's see you just fine from here
ignore corporal merwin he likes social
skills
i guess every unit has its resident
jackass well i've really said that on
the airshow
i think you're one there's lieutenant
colonel kane just taking him down to the
briefing room
yeah gotta go get prep
we'll see you in there maureen
so what's his malfunction
nick ain't been himself lately
we got caught up in a shooting a few
weeks back civilian at a bullet nick
took it hard is he combat ready
he's a big boy sir he's ready
it's odd like if you make me pick a side
they immediately made me sympathetic for
him but
i like king too now i'm all good people
who sit behind desks don't tend to catch
so many bullets you know
so this must be the one and only
satellite
i'm eric king
the one and only satellite guy
i'm eric king
lieutenant colonel eric king
the colonel full side access
sir
nice
i'm telling you when the queen [ __ ]
finds out about this she's gonna flip
her [ __ ]
ooh
rachel and i
we know each other
she'll understand also
sir that's my wife the queen [ __ ]
you're referring to is his wife
[Laughter]
amazing nice work hotshot
it's a weird thing to say to someone you
don't know very well go hot in with
queen [ __ ]
sure i'm so sorry rachel never said she
was married
we've been working apart this last year
so she's the queen [ __ ] now
she's gone up in the world if it helps
we like to think of it as a
term of achievement
right let's get you shut up i hope the
bandwidth can cope with the data i'll
leave the techy stuff to you
and i'll leave the heavy lifting subject
survey group objectives
directorate of central intelligence
intelligence intelligence the objectives
of the survey group are as stated
organized and direct intelligence
capabilities across coalition government
agencies apply intelligent expertise to
discover capture and exploit information
on individuals facilities and okay
they're looking for wmds basically
in iraq they're looking for wmds
got it
as long as you don't step on my foot all
of that makes sense
oh
the eclipse is coming back
um
i see
oh my god it's queen [ __ ]
colonel king
mrs king
eric this is my team and if you want to
brief them you clear it with me first
i'm just gonna go around this is my team
now what are you talking about
i have direct orders from centcom to
assume command of your task force
ow
are you serious
have you known me to be any other way
lieutenant colchek should be so kind
this is from sauk central it confirms
that lieutenant colonel king has assumed
control of this operation
nobody have a piece of people like that
i love it in video games they're just
literally just like boxes that people
just like
you can't make them floppy paper physics
i bet you have
strange choice okay
i guess i'll go figure it out for myself
dr stokes please prepare the
presentation
you've found something
oh have we
catacombs
[ __ ] is that
modern art or something
this is footage from the highly
classified chaos program that's supposed
to mean something to me
it's a thermal satellite system that i
personally pioneered
oh
well i'm impressed
please pioneer away
you behave like this in all your
briefings corporal
boys are just eager to catch a break sir
no harm meant
very well jason's just pee off with
these douchebags
have uncovered what appears to be an
underground storage facility this will
of course require further investigation
but i strongly suspect
where saddam's chemical weapons are
hidden
we got you you son of a [ __ ]
centcom has given the green light to
raid the facility and seize any weapons
on site
hostilities may be over but there are
hold out groups of republican guard it'd
be super interesting if it's like they
could deploy those weapons at any time
so we need to the eclipse
makes chemical weapon aliens i feel like
that's unlikely but lieutenant cole
check will lead the raid on the facility
once it's secured we'll carry out a full
weapons inspection
now listen up
there's been a change of leadership but
rachel's operational expertise and local
knowledge is just as valuable as ever
she'll be flying with us
and i want you all to show her the same
respect
any questions
are you guys like still together or like
listen
what's the situation it's travel
territory out there
make no mistake
those people are [ __ ]
i take it we're getting but
too many birds could bring them down you
just call civilians feral fasting faster
yeah that's pretty much what your mama's
missing hey careful boy
if i didn't pull out so fast
it could have been your puppy why did he
what do i think high five
all right um
we keep this thing small
if it goes south i'll pull the plug and
we can bug out with all due respect i
think i don't feel great about it either
with all due respect lieutenant cold
check it's not your decision to make
i didn't i actually don't know that i
did the right thing
merwin has a point
we spin up too many helos we'll increase
our chance of being spotted
that's why i went with it and also i
like a good stealth
we go dark until weapons are secured if
we don't break radio sounds within 24
hours centcom will mount to the right
operation
a lot of [ __ ] can go down in 24 hours
i'll quit being a [ __ ] joey's my
favorite i always go for the nerd this
is why we went to war
this is what gets us out of bed every
morning
make no mistake ladies and gentlemen
this is how we stop saddam from using
these weapons
oh so they didn't kill him they just
like kicked him out of this area
dismissed
you think that obama has a cameo in this
game
luis help me set up the equipment i'm on
it
i don't know man this don't feel right
i'm getting this tingle down the back of
my neck
oh sweetie look good rub down we'll sort
that right out huh i'm serious
got a real bad feeling about this
that's what you get from spending too
much time with eric
is there anything you can do
i mean
i'm gonna jump what else would we do
does it don't feel like there are any
other options
thank you clarice
eric
we need to talk
there's something i have to tell you
you should know
it wasn't my decision to take over your
operation
excited
rach
this is it
everything i've worked on these past
years it's ready
this is the big break we've been waiting
for
this isn't about us eric
i just want things to go back to the way
they were no no no she's no no no no
how we left it
things weren't so great between us
we've been through worse
a lot worse
nothing has changed eric
you know you're cheating on him you and
i don't think accounts is cheating but
there is no units oh great okay good
please rach
don't say that
damn no
you're not wearing your wedding yes you
accept you separated
hey
be careful with that oh [ __ ] sorry
you got in that box of tricks anyway
the [ __ ] is that
you might say but
asap enough for you this is star wars
reference i'm not even positive i got it
right i think she has a dog saver good
one check the satellite maps
not the greatest bandwidth rebels
anybody work with what we have can you
sign this 1348
huh equipment release form can you
oh sure seemed a bit delayed
also i keep feeling like i shouldn't
take my hands with the controller but
this is a lot of cutscene yeah i hear
you
oh boy you think you're a nathan drake
do you even a shot
nathan drake asked some of them a [ __ ]
it's the same what i already looked at
i shouldn't let it go okay grab it grab
it grab it
with the serving group becoming
operational nope he puts it down no
matter what okay fine
that is fine
hmm
interesting
don't mind me just looking at stuff what
is this confidential
operation iraq survey group
cent calm bandit activity disappearance
to aid workers
yves pogum and
marie or mary failed to make contact two
weeks ago presume robbed and killed all
right we've lost two huh
this is
the same thing as before
already been over like can you stop
whistling dude can you can you can you
shut up can you shut your mouth
um
i feel like i've pretty much looked at
most of this now
nick
your word i said
yeah high x flashbacks white boss
white phosphorus
okay
what is this
i don't know what that is
this is what i think it is
wp shirt
white phosphorus
it's just for pop and smoke we don't
feel good about that
these are unauthorized if we break
weapons conventions then we're just as
bad as saddam i won't allow them on this
mission this is [ __ ] we need all the
no
sergeant k there seems to be some
confusion that was an order not a talk
yeah no we don't we don't be dropping
white phosphorus out here lads we won't
be taking them thank you that's some
that's that's no
we are cool
yeah
that's like war crimes right here um
changing my webcam
that oh yeah beautiful
i'm good i'm good with the no white
phosphorus even if it would have helped
against the monsters i just you know he
contextually king does not know that
there are monsters
so
what the hell we need this crap for
what is the mobile we need to be
prepared the facility is underground
possibly under construction it's safer
this way
you want me to feel safe
you give me some more shooters
it's not a terrible request um you're
afraid of heights
tell me corporal are you afraid of
heights
please
i'm force recon i've trained in high
altitude low opening parachute jumps
hostile conditions that would make most
men wake up screaming for their mama
you've been quick picture
i hope you're more than just mouth
maureen
he's
climbing gear
[ __ ] his eyelashes is [ __ ] visible
underneath his uh
glosses
you think we'll bag chemical ali at this
facility
he's in the vicinity we'll get him
that almost makes it worth the risk
almost
well you know i'd still rather be
sitting behind a desk
sir i've heard some [ __ ] up stories
about the border
you sure you don't want air support
there's a chance we'll need him i don't
know i
we have the element of surprise on our
side i will not allow anything to be
clear i don't like really feel equipped
to take this role on
can we take a step back and think about
this for me
i've made my decision
i i would have let you make the call
dude because i have zero experience and
you've been here for my parents owned a
horse however
he ran away
about the farm on this
i have a good feeling we're gonna clear
up
i wish i shared your optimism colonel
all right lads
shall we move out are we allowed to move
out
not yet
there we go
download's complete
let's get to the helos let's do it
who wrote
what
what
you want to ask me something i can tell
by that look on your face
what do you think of him
i take it you're talking about the
skipper
skipper
hey nice guy
around here nice don't cut it
what do you think of them
like he's got something else on his mind
well
you're bagging his wife so
could be thinking about that just
putting it out there
stubborn and courageous okay
pumpkins oh spooky season is it october
the pumpkin month
spice latte indeed
and i get
then
find zayn
no
harsh but fair
okay somebody broke a picture
that's the lighting and this is
beautiful it's
good environments
i get university shield dear zane the
board has approved your application for
admission to highgate university to read
mythology ba in an academic year 2003
2004 which commences on september 2nd
2003. this offer is conditional upon
your agreement to fulfill the following
requirements
complete college
students visa
let me tell you i had a student's visa
before i had my current visa which is um
my current visa is i'm an alien of
extraordinary ability which is like a
visa for people who have skills
um
the student's visa was much easier but
still a real pain in the ass
especially
if you're coming from
a country that is not predominantly
white oh is it gonna be up this way
all right your apartment's bigger than
mine dude you you're rolling in it
you're loaded
these cameras are
a real thing though
can we just back it up a little bit
this one
hmm
he left his jumper
oh my
how good he
oh
we weren't looking for the jumper
i apologize for the mockery
i don't know what i'm looking at watches
you've been stealing
selling
oh the pizza excuse me
[Music]
stolen goods
foreign
foreign
you didn't have to hang up on her she
didn't do it
captain battery island
i don't feel like we're going to go
against the military
i feel like you kind of got to do that
look how obedient i am
i just feel like he would have got
scolded if he'd said the sun thing and
it wouldn't it wouldn't happen there's
no way
oh yeah i didn't look at the gift is it
his birthday or something
didn't we say no oh it's just us
we can take a helicopter we just didn't
want anyone else to join us
they both swallow marines
that's pretty good boy
hey look your mama's so nasty
i called it for phone sex now i got a
[ __ ] ear infection it's pretty good
too
well damn
how long have you been sitting on now oh
yeah you like that
yeah i should tell more of those bad
boys lined up yeah that's what your
momma said you do want to cut the
[ __ ] i mean they're on a plane karen
hey what else are they supposed to do
right now
fine wmds from the copter
i'm surprised your mom lets women into
your bedroom
don't want her getting jealous now
hey
the [ __ ] y'all laughing at
sergeant k i need you to establish
contact with the aywax cp on four hour
intervals
sergeant k
are you with me
yeah i got it contact cp every four
hours
[Music]
i need you here with me can i count on
you
i'll ask you one more time can i count
on you
yeah i got you
um
yeah i got you back got your back nikki
no matter what
i know it
make sure you do
it's amplified
semper fi
what's that some kind of boy scout thing
their faces look so good
i wonder if that's always why they
always go so close
they're like we know what we're good at
faces
faces in your face
all right check it out
they say to never look back when you're
disembarking the helo otherwise you
curse the whole team
that's gotta be about the stupidest
thing i have ever heard the eyes look
really good just the eyelashes through
glasses and not great that's it
eyes forward at all times if you look
backwards in a war zone it's no wonder
you get your ass shot off
we're good to go marines this is what we
were sent here to do and may god be my
witness we're going to succeed
amen to that brother
i'd never even heard of that term before
halo so
that's where i get most of my cultural
staples from is
video games
[Music]
all right drop it in hot let's do it
yikes
it's not going to go down well for any
of you because the the eclipse situation
there's a class
not because you looked at the helicopter
i just need you to know that that was
not not why your day is about to go to
[ __ ]
oh nice sweater
sir we've been made
awaiting orders
um
i think they said he was confident right
the building in front copy that cqc
was he confident and
no he was rational and defensive or
something i don't remember damn it
can we take a sweater also i don't feel
great about this
i don't feel great about this maybe i
shouldn't have shot him
they're just in their houses
i have regrets already i've already made
the wrong choice
prisoners are playing ball
roger
get corporal merwin to pop yellow smoke
at the lc and bring in the colonel
what
what did you just say to me
this raid's a bust
these people are not the enemy they're
just shepherds
lieutenant cold check sit rep if you
will
sure we secured the farm with minimal
casualties casualties how minimal are we
talking took one down was this casualty
a hostile or a civilian yeah we didn't
get a chance to make it it's my bad i
don't feel good about it was he armed
have you located an entrance to the
underground silo negative sir
there is one it's well camouflaged
if there is one what does that mean
lieutenant
we have yet to carry out a full search
we'll find it sir
good job lieutenant
silo everybody's so argumentative
they're just so ready to fight
that went smoothly you think got a place
locked down tighter than a virgin do not
finish that sentence corporal
are they ready for questioning yeah just
don't ask them any tough physics
questions let's go
stay sharp
if anyone so much as raises an eyebrow i
want to know about it copy that
i don't know about you guys but
something doesn't feel right about this
place oh yeah so is that this uh
i bet you he lives until the end because
he's a douchebag
yeah you want to find out what happens
when you piss it off
i'm sorry about that i thought i don't
forget about it that just
oops well i don't feel good about
this either
he doesn't look like a hostile
all due respect but you weren't there
and i ain't taking no chances
well that's just great it is what it is
no lieutenant it's not
you killed a man
but maybe we can use this to our
advantage
no i'm sorry about that
i apologize about the man who died
i hope he didn't have kids
or a wife
is
don't feel like it's your place to do
anything
[Music]
the hell is that
some kind of effigy
possibly pagan is it going to be a map
of some kind
that's a threat
i wonder if it's um
huh
if it's supposed to be some kind of
reference to the
cuss and the eclipse and stuff well what
i've had enough of this corporal keep an
eye on the captives
you heard him marine
i mean there's only three of them right
oh yeah we didn't interrogate them
or just just keep an eye on them what am
i did you want me to do something in
here
i think maybe i'm supposed to go with
her and she meant that they were
supposed to people look out ooh frame
rates tell me where the silo is
this man was armed ma'am
everyone in this country is armed
ah
do that again and i'll tear you up into
pieces and feed you to the [ __ ]
jackals i probably should have heard him
there
i just have to uh
she's not really intimidating in arabic
weirdly enough
also i wonder if they're doing the
arabic correctly if i have any uh
subscribers who are watching this video
who know the answer that please let me
know because i feel like they often um
video games are often really bad at
arabic
jack [ __ ] there was a silo where's all
the tracks nah
man this is a fishing expedition his
precious chaos has got it all i don't
know about that we follow orders
sergeant the search is far from over
i sir
i don't feel like a satellite is going
to get this kind of [ __ ] wrong but maybe
that's just me
hmm
got some gas masks here a lot of gas
masks
what's what's the secret about it
oh black stains
black stains
that might not mean anything
who is always whistling
i can't see them doing it when there's
three of them
oh boy
that's heroin
just keeps getting better but i am
these people are nothing but common
crooks what the [ __ ] was eric thinking i
want this place turned inside out
that's a lot of heroin i presume
i'll be honest
don't actually know
i think it is
bricks of heroin seems like it's worth a
lot of money
apt
i don't know if i did that correctly
though
who died
maybe not somebody i know
that was [ __ ] close
[ __ ] rush huh
rachel
where are you
rachel
[Music]
so clearly
the heroin
isn't gonna be it like you don't have
the government doesn't run in to be like
no the heroin farm so they are they got
our dealers oh no
right [ __ ] you well unless they like
know there's a small group of americans
and they want to take them out of
something
[Music]
sometimes i like to tell a soldier to
get
grenades [ __ ] be real useful right now
i'm not using white phosphorus on people
i wouldn't use them anyway no it's it's
super [ __ ] up dude you can't you can't
be doing them tings
i'm gonna flank him give me some cover
and get joey out of there
oh
would he have tripped
stupid soldier can't even open a gate
the um aiming reticle thing is like
super forgiving it lets you get ages
away
oh cool flip dude
that was sick
all right oh my
you [ __ ] dying man
oh it was joey oh my favorite got shot
well still calm down
flesh when it's a paper cut
i don't love that
i don't love that first
ah
ah
oh did i do that because i didn't shoot
those dudes fast enough
oh god
it feels bad it feels bad it doesn't
feel good
[ __ ]
i bet you moen lives forever i stand by
it
and fight back
god damn it
all calls signs this is dropkick silence
lifted could someone give me a sip rep
on the contact over dropkick this is
killjoy 2 we are under fire and going
down targets have advanced into the ld
this get any worse
i mean yeah that could be like a curse
get down on the floor i swear i'll put a
[ __ ] hole through you
uh
did you shoot him in the leg
yeah okay
oh no i killed him
i killed him
you better know i was just trying to put
him down
no more killing
uh
oh
oh my
[ __ ] way
what are they
it's not a sinkhole rachel
rachel
dude you gotta you gotta stop being so
caught up about
your ex
back in the mouth
oh
cool
conveniently placed holes for our
protagonists to fall into
oh my
what's your way of telling me the
radio's out
i actually
think
that that's a good place to leave part
one of this um i will have the next
episode episode of this up tomorrow
morning and then i might like skip a day
or so but i think it's about five hours
so maybe five or six parts this would be
part one um like i said these games
always tend to start off like pretty
chill in the beginning before they start
to get scary and ramp up in scariness
towards the end so we're starting very
chill right now
but you've got characters i'm interested
in i like the setting a lot i'm curious
about the mystery and what's gonna be
going on down here so i am definitely
interested
to keep playing more thank you all for
watching and i will see you very soon
for part two bye